With such a huge selection on Netflix, finding
a good movie can be a daunting task.
That's why we've gone through the Netflix
line-up to find the best little-seen films
available.
From horror to comedy to action, here are
the best Netflix gems you probably haven't
seen yet.
The Wraith
Back in the technicolor '80s, there was a
wonderful movie called The Wraith.
The idea: a murdered street racer returns
from the grave to get revenge on a bunch of
street punks in an undead muscle car.
As far as terrible-but-awesome premises go,
this sits somewhere near the top of the stack.
And yet in spite of everything it's got going
against it, The Wraith actually works.
It's solid B-movie material elevated to hidden
gem status by colorful characters, surprisingly
good special effects, and fun dialogue.
The Wraith knows full well what it is, and
it doesn't take itself too seriously.
Kill Me Three Times
Simon Pegg is a modern cult megastar, but
this hilarious crime thriller still managed
to fly under the radar on its 2014 release.
With a kinetic style reminiscent of Guy Ritchie's
good films, Kill Me Three Times follows three
intertwined stories of ordinary people driven
to the brink, all of it linked by one man
with a very hitman mustache.
A Simon Pegg hitman mustache.
At times brutal, touching, and hilarious — sometimes
all at once — you won't find a more flat-out
fun movie than Kill Me Three Times.
Creep
Who knew a film with a cast of exactly two
people could be so enthralling?
Yeah, you might groan at first: if Creep had
a downside, it would be the decision to make
it in jerky, handheld, found-footage style.
But Creep pulls it off, and beautifully at
that.
In fact, this may be the first film since
The Blair Witch Project that couldn't have
been filmed any other way, and arguably the
first good one.
Creep switches seamlessly between drama, comedy,
and horror thanks mostly to a near-perfect
performance by mumbling maniac Mark Duplass.
Whatever else you take away from it, there's
no doubt Creep will give you, well, the creeps.
Bronson
Back in 2008, before he was a household name,
Tom Hardy starred in a bizarre biopic called
Bronson.
In real life, Charles Bronson — whose real
name was Michael Peterson before he renamed
himself after the actor — has spent more
than 40 years in prison and was dubbed "the
most violent prisoner in Britain" — even
though he's never killed anyone.
When Tom Hardy was first tapped to star in
the movie, the real Bronson was less than
impressed by the actor.
But after Hardy gained a ton of weight and
studied the way the real-life criminal moved,
Bronson changed his tune, saying, "Tom looks
more like me than I look like me."
If you were impressed by Bane and Mad Max
Rockatansky, don't miss out on Bronson.
It's got its weird moments, but the movie
is insanity at its best.
"Ha ha."
Ravenous
There aren't a lot of movies that will make
you question your dinner, but from the very
first frame, Ravenous turns rare steak into
an entre to be regarded with suspicion.
Starring Guy Pearce and Robert Carlyle, this
1999 gem plays like a horror movie on the
surface, but does so with a heart of comedic
black gold.
While it begins as a seemingly straightforward
story of an army captain assigned to the remote
Sierra Nevada mountains after the Mexican-American
War, Ravenous quickly moves into territory
that's hard to classify.
There's the horror of cannibalism in the isolated
mountains, the action of a spaghetti Western,
a thick smattering of tongue-in-cheek humor,
and a pulsing vein of modern satire woven
throughout.
All of it comes together into an extremely
entertaining, offbeat movie experience that
you won't forget anytime soon.
Unfortunately, the film's marketing sent people
to theaters expecting a more mainstream, slapstick
comedy, not the violent, black humor they
ended up watching.
As a result, Ravenous was chewed to pieces
by critics and limped through theaters earning
a measly $2 million—half of which came during
its opening weekend.
Beyond the Gates
You could probably get away with calling this
movie Jumanji 2: This Time with Demons, but
that wouldn't be entirely fair to Beyond the
Gates, a horror thriller about two brothers
who find a VHS board game in their recently
deceased father's video store.
Video board games were a real, weird thing
in the VCR's heyday, so there's probably a
nostalgia element to Beyond the Gates if you
were one of the 30 or 40 people who ever played
one.
But for everyone else, the idea of a video
that knows what you're doing lends as much
to the fantasy element of the film as the
hellish repercussions the brothers experience
as they fall deeper into the game.
Hellish, in this case, is of course totally
literal.
The more the brothers play, the more the game
begins to bleed into the real world, turning
their home into the devil's suburban dreamhouse.
It's a fun, twisted film, perfect for a rainy
night.
Look Who's Back
This low-key German satire is both unexpected
and surprisingly hilarious.
Look Who's Back starts with Hitler waking
up in in a park in modern Berlin, still in
uniform, with no idea how he got there.
The first people he meets think he's a crazy
hobo, the next ones think he's a Method actor
doing a bit, and before long, Hitler's all
over the news as the next big German comedian…and
the people love him.
In fact, it's less a satire on Hitler and
more a social commentary on modern-day Germany
as a whole.
On top of all that, it's pretty funny.
Look Who's Back is definitely a weird combo,
but it's one that happens to work extremely
well.
Uncanny
If you liked Ex Machina, you'll be right at
home with Uncanny, a tight, claustrophobic
movie about a brilliant roboticist named David
Kressen who builds the perfect artificial
intelligence.
Or is it?
When the robot's behavior grows more sinister,
the programmer and his newfound girlfriend,
a journalist on assignment to write about
Kressen's achievements, find themselves trapped
in Kressen's lab with an uncannily human creature
who's suddenly become painfully unpredictable.
Beautifully shot and steeped in tension you
could cut with a bonesaw, Uncanny is a fantastic
hidden sci-fi thriller.
With incredible performances from everyone
involved, you won't be able to look away until
the end.
The Void
In many ways, the John Carpenter horror thrillers
of the '80s were a genre unto themselves.
Movies like The Thing and Prince of Darkness
reveled in violence and body horror without
leaning on it as a pure shock tactic — and
somehow, in 2017, a small sci-fi horror film
slipped unnoticed into that exclusive genre.
The Void is a throwback to those '80s creature
features in many ways, from the practical
monster effects to the subdued, foreboding
atmosphere, but it also stands on its own
as a bloody good sci-fi creepfest.
Don't miss it.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!